you will find in my speech today themes
of obviously a building city so urbanism
but really it's a story about
entrepreneurship it's a story about
persistence about innovation about
risk-taking a little bit of leadership
and personal growth but before I start
the narrative every story needs a motive
so I was shocked when I looked at this
picture what do you see it's moving this
picture not the other one
what do you see when I first looked at
it how much risk are these guys taking
so dangerous right really unbelievable
what they're trying to do when I've had
god why are these guys doing with their
future but then when you really stare at
it some new meaning emerges if you look
at this there is you know what they're
doing
ask old sidewalks keen okay it's a stunt
these guys get in the car there's a
fourth one driving so four guys get in a
car they get the car to speed get it to
balance on two tires and then they get
out of the car start removing the tires
from the back and the front and
switching them and then they all go back
into the car and they rebalance it
just go to Jeff Alou I don't know why
you're doing this but to get there to
get there and here's my point
you need the resistance you need
training
teamwork there's almost a level of
perfecting your vocation and the moral
of the story is the following these are
very talented people they just chose
this to spend their talents on frankly
because there is very little else this
is by the way is not a Saudi story there
are 600 million people around the world
that will need jobs over the next 10
years
it's an Arab world story but it's also a
global story it's an emerging market
story and we can't use old methods all
formulas and expect new results and
governments around the world have
unfortunately been trying to do just
that trying to do more of the same thing
it is time for innovation and
public-private partnership
Saudi Arabia despite having huge oil
reserves and big financial capacity
tried to do just that the late King
Abdullah in 2005 just five months by the
way after he was he became King launched
a new project it's a brand new city from
scratch for 2 million people physically
it is the size of Washington DC so very
sizable and the idea was for the first
time the government of Saudi Arabia
knows how to build cities they build
Jubail and Yanbu there's our new
industrial cities that we launched 35
years ago but the idea here is for the
government today to take a back seat and
give the private sector the opportunity
to lead that was idea so for the first
time in global history a project of this
size was given to the private sector
this problem practically
they the largest private sector project
in the world a price tag of a hundred
billion dollars what's more interesting
it was also a startup because there was
no company no team and it was listed day
one so every kind of complication you
can imagine was put right here so I
joined this initiative in 2008 January
2008 about two years after it was
launched and I have had never built
anything before I was 30 years old just
three years after graduating from
Stanford my only training and this was
actually Sim City how many of you played
Sim City come on be honest raise your
hands so you're all qualified to do my
job and I did it by the way by
coincidence I was I I had a hard time
keeping up in class so I spent my
sophomore year of college playing Sim
City and that was my training actually
it turned out to be good training
because all of my cities as mayor of
these subsidies failed and went bankrupt
but I have experience and one of the
things I learned very early on on the
job is that this is a really really
competitive space in fact there are two
hundred and forty-eight thousand cities
around the world
two hundred and forty-eight thousand
cities and each one of them is a unique
product they all compete for us to move
there and for companies to set up so
here you really as a city need to have a
clear strategy you really need to know
where you're going to be when you grow
up and we decided that this is going to
be a global logistics and manufacturing
hub why two reasons number one the city
is local
dated under Etsy we're 23% of gold a
global trade goes 23% almost a quarter
of global trade east/west comes through
the Red Sea but there is no significant
port that can actually address this
market and provide the logistics
required for it that's one the second
idea is very simple but even less well
known you see this area all of these
countries around the Red Sea this is
what we call the Red Sea region there
are 650 million people living there
today country's growing at anywhere
between 6 to 12 percent in terms of GDP
not bad right good market but it by 2050
this market will be 1.3 billion people
so this is as a region it is the next
China in terms of potential so if you
are a goal global corporate you can't
address all of these countries by being
located all of them you need economies
of scale so the idea is we establish
Saudi Arabia through King Abdullah
economic City as a hub for these
companies that's the basic idea and so
we created this master plan the master
plan has a port a mega port it's gonna
be amongst the top ten ports in the
world an industrial zone so let me see
if I can point with this can I point
with this yes there you go innovation
one of the largest industrial zone in
the region and then residential
commercial and other developments all
over the rest of the city so you see
these colors are all of the communities
right now the adventure communities
we're building and there is a high-speed
railway connecting us with the largest
three three cities in the region Mecca
and Medina
Angela so about ten million people that
can get here within less than an hour
good market
and that was the vision this this was it
so where are we now nine years later as
of today we have a port that is 2.7
million container and capacity by next
year we'll have the largest port in
Saudi Arabia definitely the largest on
the Red Sea fully privatized port by the
way and these cranes are the tallest in
the world and because we want to engage
the communities around us we have
trained people from villages around us
in fact the port operating room today
has 90 women exclusively women from
villages around us they actually tell
all of the boys were to put the
containers so that's the port we also
have one of the most successful
industrial zones in the region
definitely in Saudi Arabia is the most
successful in an oil-based industrial
zone we have attracted attracted
companies from around the world
including Mars
Sanofi Pfizer and others many of them
are establishing manufacturing
facilities in the kingdom for the first
time but some of them are in the region
for the first time again creating jobs
and this was the second most important
learning that resident the residential
developments actually do not create
economic development you know when when
you have developers go into a city to
develop real estate what they're doing
is tapping to an economic cycle that
already exists there are jobs and they
are simply providing residents right so
we have learned that this does not work
and therefore we've created the jobs and
then we had to create the developments
that will try to accommodate the the
jobs that were and the people that are
moving in for the jobs so we created
different income segment solutions so we
have as you can see six different
communities each one of them addressing
a different income segment so we have
all the way from labor villages all the
way to high-end you can see golf courses
etc there
but we introduced two interesting ideas
into the mix first of all equity in
terms of providing all amenities within
every community so every community has
the same level of amenities so all of
them have some kind of beach beach
access some public amenities and
facilities and even some level of
education even professional continuing
education and the second is we stagger
them so they're actually distinct but
staggered so you can actually move from
each one to the other as your career
grows so idea is you graduate you start
you got a job you start earning income
you invest in your equity in your home
very quickly on and you have then
mobility within the community moving
from one to the other and in fact
because of the strategy last year
although this is a completely new
development we became the largest
developer in terms of sales in the
country we've sold 2,500 units more than
anybody else in the country and one of
the things that I also learned is on the
importance of education they say to
build a great city you only need to do
is build a great university and wait 200
years
I don't have 200 years so the idea is
the idea is to bring education as much
as possible to the beginning of the city
development so we're building K through
12 schools this is our first school it's
actually a very successful school it
will have the first also boarding
component and the country so we can
board students we're working with Babson
on a college of entrepreneurship and
business and we are doing a lot of
training for you know 90-day base
training just rehabilitation post-post
schooling so we have a lot of high
school graduates in the region we've
trained a thousand about just 90 days
and these are if you think about the
opportunities that we have we are
basically in the mainstream right we
already are you're already very
successful you go into a great school
the employers come to you you have
family members you have friends and
network right but if you're in a village
and you graduated from high school and
your parents are not employed you
absolutely have no access to the market
in fact many of these students in these
villages or these these five 66-year
graduates and post high school had no
access to the job market they can't even
know and they don't even know where to
look for a job they don't know how to
write a resume they don't know how to
interview so that's all we did we did 90
days of training English career
management computer skills etc 90 days
what do you think was the success rate
throw number percent risk takers I like
that I like it there was 88% 88% of the
graduates of this program either got a
job went into higher education and the
11 percent of them actually started
their own companies so again it's about
doing the little things that matter the
most
okay so this is this is something I'm
super super excited about Saudi Arabia
is not known for to be a great tourist
destination right so we're actually
going heavily into tourism you know you
get you build the largest port the most
successful industrial zone you become
the largest the residential developer
and gets to your head here we're gonna
do tourism so how do you think we're
gonna do it how can we compete with
Dubai Paris San Francisco all of these
great places that attract millions and
millions of people to them any ideas
exactly we don't have to
we are the 17th most visited country in
the world every year also in addition to
that we export 10 million Saudis around
the world on vacation on vacation 30
days so we're trying to create a
location within Saudi Arabia that
leverage is the incredible location we
are in in fact here is a taste we have
some of the most beautiful coral reefs
in the world 6,000 years old almost 5000
species many of them unique 44 are
sharks but we don't talk about it
because it's not good for tourism and in
creating a destination you need to
leverage the space you are you need a
sense of place right so leveraging the
50 kilometers or 35 miles of seafront is
one the second is because we live in the
GCC and the temperature is quite hot all
year round we've got it used to
air-conditioning so we hardly leave our
homes we have hardly have you know being
an environment where I can walk out
here into the street is actually quite
unique and wonderful and that's why we
all love the Bay Area in fact 50% of you
won't leave this area but the idea is
how can we create a city that will allow
you to reengage with the environment so
we did something that is very
interesting it was part of my learning
as well the first master plan which you
didn't see this is a second this is the
fourth master plan but the first master
plan made the city look like Venice was
beautiful it was almost 50 miles of
waterways inside the city okay and I
learned that that is the most harmful
thing you can do to the environment and
to the city simply was over engineered
but that's the way you build cities even
ten years ago okay so what we did is
very simple set up my wife here and I
were in New York during hurricane sandy
and we got stuck and I learned the
lesson of not to go against the
environment not to try to bend the
environment to our well as human beings
so we went back to our master planners
and we said how can we make this the
most ecologically friendly city in the
world so we removed all of the canals we
simply let the water flow where it
always flowed for the past 2,000 3,000
years and go right into the sea and we
stepped back all of our developments
about 60 70 meters and some areas 400
meters from the sea we had a beautiful
lagoon that was natural that we made
into a Preserve so nobody can touch it
and the idea is sometimes that's the
right thing to do when you have a city
with this kind of environment around it
but most importantly it wasn't that when
lose the city will become more appealing
but also we had even more areas to
develop because it was cheaper to
develop the city without the canals so
it turns out to be a win-win solution to
be ecologically friendly
and I promise you this is my final slide
so I try to remember how wonderful it
was to be here I remember strolling back
and forth going out of my golf class
coming back to corporate finance and
just go through this campus was
unbelievable for me and I remember that
I could have almost not been here not
that school but what I'm doing doing
what I'm doing in fact I try to think
about the series of steps and decisions
that I made in my career because I can
tell you when I was there I didn't not
think that I would be building a city in
ten years it was simple
there was the path of least resistance
that I could have taken I was doing
really well back in the employer that I
was working for coming here for two
years and going back that would have
been the easiest I had a good reputation
I already build the track record I was
gonna go back and do hopefully really
well okay but I decided to move and it
doesn't matter what decision I made at
the time what matters is how I made it
so basically what I did I didn't say I
wanted to be X Y & Z in ten years I said
here's what I want to feel like in ten
years I want I want ability to have
influence to produce results in the
country you know like you you hear the
change organizations change the world
and I think you actually start believing
it after two years and I said I wanted
to have impact and has to be positive
impact so every decision I made
career-wise
was was about just getting me closer to
having impact that's what I cared about
a few if it's financial security that
you care about great do that but it's
all about deciding today just before you
cement your career in any field
what should it feel like in five years
at ten years downline and I think that
is the
biggest learning I've had over the past
ten years thank you so much I'm sorry it
took so long to get here but I hope you
enjoyed it thank you so we're gonna open
up for questions
hi my name is Joey nawaki I'm doing a
PhD in the engineering school and I mean
actually very interesting in development
of cities by the private sector or a
partnership between the public in the
private sector thank you very much for
this presentation it's very inspiring
can you talk a little more about why was
better building we said we've the
private sector and not with the
governments and maybe some of the
challenges when building just with
private sector and not maybe involving
the government as much and the public I
think one of the biggest issues is is
it's really a partnership at the end of
the day the private sector can't do
something to speak on their own it's not
about the financial it's about you know
an ecosystem this city has to be
connected with roads with power with it
has to be part of something right
and so we leverage the the fact that we
have a partnership with the government a
lot but the challenge obviously with
private sector leadership of this is
risk most of the time it was massive
risks we had to take at the beginning on
individual infrastructure or soft
infrastructure fuel projects nobody
would take any of these risks on their
own right but when you put them together
they resulted in almost incredible risk
what we call risk on risk right so let
me give you an example so we're starting
up I want to build a school right so
people can move into the city and live
so I go out and say hey who would build
a school with me right and everybody
would say no why because to get students
they need jobs they need people living
in the city and so it created this kind
of
circle vicious circle if you will of a
vicious cycle of just what we call risk
on risk every sector we try to go and
out and get a partner in they said the
same thing there's demand risk your
delivery disk we risk on your end etc
and they require so much demand risk
management so you they'll tell you why
don't you off take you know the 500
students right so it was big challenge
in fact most of the banks wouldn't
finance us at all at the beginning at
all and so it was a challenge to sort of
focus on which sectors do we work on and
one of the biggest mistakes we made as
we try to do too much at the beginning
you know the Studer ISM strategy I'm
talking about it was a the idea was
started in 2008 but we we couldn't
pursue it at the time was just too much
so we went back to focus on what would
actually drive jobs immediately and
focus on the port industrial zone and
then successively we were moving to
other sectors as they become right for
it
another question one I'm curious as you
you talked a little bit about hiring
local workers you probably have a huge
demand for talent and I'm wondering how
you think about developing local talent
and hiring local versus bringing in
people who know how to do the work now
and and what the trade-off is there yeah
I think it's about doing both so in our
company we have 24 nationalities idea if
you want to build a global city you have
to have glue and know-how and you have
you need these networks from all around
the world of technical know-how but also
social networks so they can attract
people to come here so we definitely
focus on attracting the best talent from
around the world but ultimately this
this city has to benefit Saudis that's
the idea behind it right so so we focus
focus in a big way on attracting local
talent and on training so I talked about
some of the programs about bringing
people back into the workforce but we
also do for example career days I'll
give you one one such
event we did in December December 26 of
last year we did an event so we worked
with all of the employers that are now
working with us 25 of them signed up for
1,700 jobs they opened 1,700 jobs for
anybody that is interested we we
announced the career fair online 9:00
a.m. in the morning by 11:00 we had
6,000 people register by 5:00 we had
12,000 by 9:00 p.m. we closed the
registration we had 20,000 registered so
I thought okay this is this is quantity
I'm sure there's no quality it's just
lots of people needing jobs and then I
came to the career fair and I met with
every employer the feedback was
unbelievable I said we've never seen so
much talent in Saudi Arabia and the
reason is simple we have 160,000 Saudi
students studying now abroad and
starting to graduate and go back home
and they are very very qualified they're
studying here they're studying in the UK
in Europe China Japan everywhere so
we're gonna find a huge influx of talent
coming in and then I'm very grateful
that the government made this decision
ten years ago thank you so much for
speaking with us today I want to know
when you're walking through the city or
waking up in the morning what things do
you see your experience that proved to
you that the city is what you want it to
be and in 5-10 years what things do you
hope you'll be seeing that show it's
moving in the right direction what a
great question in fact I can tell you
look this I've been doing this for seven
years and a half and it's been like a
hundred days since then right in my
first hundred days I work as hard as
hard now as I did in my first hundred
days and the reason and it's part of the
problem I'll have in the future is it's
so wonderful to go and see the work that
you want to you what you want to do
physically come out of the ground you
see people just you know when you have a
restaurant opening and they say
it's fantastic you see people coming in
and experiencing and you see this the
space and how people interact with it
and I get so much energy showing people
the city some of you are came over for
the Saudi trip and came over to to cake
for it right some some did and you know
this is the kind of experience that I
love because I see the city every time
nu and gives me energy for the next day
and the next day and the next day so in
five years by 2020 and I don't like to
have plans beyond five years because you
know nobody knows what's gonna happen
after five years we plan on getting to a
population of 50,000 we are at almost
3,000 now we're doubling population
every six months as people are moving in
for their jobs taking up residence and
50,000 turns out to be a very important
number it is actually the number of
population that is required for the city
to be self-sustaining in terms of growth
you no longer need to do some induce
economic development per se actually can
grow and so on its enough scale so
that's my target okay so thanks a lot
for coming there's a lot of us who are
big geeks about cities in the room so
I'm really excited to hear this story
one question is your vision for how to
build build a city is also very unique
and I imagine there's a lot of city
planners around the world and other
experts who run cities who question your
philosophy I'm just kind of curious what
the most interesting conversations are
that you have when you present this
around the world and to others who have
other ideas on how to do this that's not
maybe private sector first it's
government lead and the second is more
personal kind of what from your past has
been the most helpful for you maybe
besides Sim City that got you that helps
you on a day-to-day basis vision vision
what you want out of this project yeah
two very good questions the first one
also relates to which cities impact me
the most in terms of saying the the or
trying to emulate and turns out to be
two cities that started this whole thing
one is Singapore because it's a perfect
example of a city state 60 years
ago it's C locked so you don't you know
it can't grow and how they have managed
not to only make it into an economic
powerhouse a trading hub but also for it
to be really a city that has been
constant renewal and how they manage the
developments around I think that was
that was an inspiration in fact the late
Lee Kuan Yew helped us with the first
master plan we had a meeting with them
and he said look you know here's your
master plan doesn't work and next day he
came in with on a piece of paper said oh
we should move the educational district
here you should move the industrial here
you should do this do that and that was
a master planning one on one for me
which is on master planning is almost
about logic always about logic and the
second one is Dubai to be honest Dubai
is a regional example of a great success
in different sectors around services
around trade becoming a trading hub and
now tourism you wouldn't believe that
Dubai could be a such a great tourist
destination ten years ago 12 years ago
so it's about what is possible otherwise
I love cities all around the world and I
find that each one of these cities has
its own challenges it was also very
unique in certain ways and we so we try
to take from them what we think would
work in a local context and the second
question sorry was about yeah actually
the most important part now is track
record when you see what is what you
could do with very little but just
thinking very strongly about what
strategy you will have for each sector
and you see that being successful it is
and you know it gives you such great
confidence and the second is around
resistance this might seem obvious today
but even a few years ago and many of the
Saudis and the room will tell you this
was considered a joke in fact they used
to call it
cartoon City cartoon City yeah so that
was the
and now it's and Saudi considered the
ultimate public-private partnership at a
time when oil prices have dropped and
and the government is looking more for
private sector participation so thank
you okay it's helpful to have the
microphone that way I don't have to
choose and become less popular than
already mine is mine is a little bit of
a follow up to that question which is
some plants that he's obviously don't
have the best reputation alluded to the
joke earlier one of the reasons why when
you accelerate I guess eight hundred
years of history and yeah in a decade
and it's difficult to do that without
developing I think a large sense of
hubris so I wonder like on your team are
the things you guys specifically do to
make sure to keep yourselves in check
with historical forces or social forces
etc yeah actually this is this turns out
to be where being private and being
publicly listed most helpful so the
problem with cities that have been
developed in 20 years mostly our
government master planner usually a
great architect comes up with the plan
I'm not gonna mention names because I
don't want to get in trouble this is
recorded and being but I can tell you
that sometimes they forget the basics
actually cities are about the people not
the buildings and people love retail
okay and most planners forget that
retail is important so the people that
you some of the cities that you're
talking about literally just simply
forgot to put in retail and that's it
the buildings are fantastic you can walk
between them but there's no place to
interact no place to sit so it's these
little examples and I mentioned the
private sector aspect and being listed
for one important reason it is a
feedback mechanism usually when the
government does something and they have
a great 20 year plan they don't have
feedback they don't get feedback they
just simply build it right for us being
publicly listed every quarter I have the
pressure of having to show results and
you can look at the results as just
profit or you can look at them as value
creation
so I think the private sector the power
of the private sector is to create value
share it with your customer and the rest
is profit right so the more value we
create the more value we share and
profit we make so the idea that every
quarter we have to do this is actually
quite powerful because it actually
forces you to look at the business model
and see why it's not working
it doesn't take us three years four
years five years to figure out we can
figure out immediately if something is
not selling then we know there's
something wrong with it
that's why we became the largest
developer last year because all our
product range has been very successful
and it's addressing market needs okay so
we have a we have a micro I welcome back
and Kent Kuran MBA one you mentioned a
hundred billion dollar price tag and I
was wondering if you could comment on
the private and public sources of
capital both past and expected in the
future and if the lower oil price has
led you to Rhys cope some of the project
very good question we started with the
capitalization of 25 billion dollars
trying to do a project for a hundred
billion dollars and it turns out to be
the biggest challenge of all because to
build a hundred billion dollars worth of
city right you need to recycle the 25
billion dollars which means you have to
buy
develop sell develop sell develop self
which means you can't hold on to
anything you you know your prized assets
at some point somebody interested so
that's biggest challenge that we have we
have been very successful lately at
attracting also Bank that I talked about
the challenge of being debt financed
which is important but now we are at
stage where the banks are offering us
their balance sheets in a big way so
that is there's quite a development
given the riskiness of the project at
the earlier stages so this is it and
idea is that we the tower capitalisation
is sufficient going forward given that
our debt to equity
is improving typically in a project of
infrastructure you will have 80% debt
and 20% equity we have had a hundred
percent equity the whole time up to a
few years back so we still have a lot of
leeway thank you can you talk about sort
of the long-term strategy for the city
whether it will be continued to be
publicly listed what does that look like
in terms of your return profile or sort
of what the economic aim for the city is
and how that relates to managing people
you talked about how cities are about
people and maybe that's aligned with
economic game maybe it's at odds but I'm
curious your reactions it's a it's a
good question the answer is in two we
are now moving into separating the
development from the operation of the
city so development has its own nature
it developed infrastructure you develop
buildings you sell all your rent etc so
that's one aspect and here you know it's
all about creating economic value and
just driving jobs job jobs and then
president's resident residence
the operation is quite different okay
see I think the operating a city should
be done by the residence of the city in
a sense and so we are creating a whole
governance structure around if you buy a
unit or a home in the city you get
shares and this new operating entity
that will allow you to have General
Assembly's vote in a group of leaders
for the operation of the city and then
they elect an executive or appoint an
executive to lead the most important
aspect is that executive can and should
be fired when they don't perform because
ultimately the city the operation of a
city is around making sure the city is
safe it's clean cetera and that is I
believe an executive job it needs you
need to have as much representation and
the operation as possible as much
transparency as possible but ultimately
and it's an executive job so that's why
we're separating the the operation in
terms of our return
while we have been profitable since 2011
our growth and top-line bottom line has
been 30% a year we are still doing 100
million dollars a year on a two and a
half billion dollar capitalization our
stock is still undervalued and hit but I
think by by next year or the year after
it will change people will discover the
kind of value has been created by end of
next year we would have wiped out all of
the losses that we had in the financial
crisis and we'll have our land bank
worth probably will be 40 billion
dollars I have the mic no yeah great by
the way great presentation thank you I
have two questions
the first one is what would be the best
or the most interesting opportunity
right now that is not fulfilled at the
city whether it's a service sector or
industrial sector so if somebody would
come and say I want to invest what would
you recommend what is the demand that is
not fulfilled the second question is as
a can you establish a subsidiary of a
foreign company to operate in in the
economic zone yeah the second one is
easy yes 100% ownership we are we even
allow ownership of real estate for
individuals foreign and local so it's a
hundred percent allowed in Saudi Arabia
especially in Camden our city the
biggest opportunity today actually is
why which is why I'm here in the valley
is around IOT the Internet of Things
this concept of smart city and the
concept were launching of a perfect home
since I joined in 2008 people have been
talking about smart cities right how
many of you heard of a smart city
how many of you have seen a smart city
okay and the problem will be with with
the concept is Authority the view
diffusion fuel there's nobody can make
the decision
there is different authorities
technology risk who's gonna take the
risk if you're in government I don't
want to do an implementation most of
them you can't bid out because it's
unique technology right so how do you
price it in a public tender so you can
make decisions and the big companies are
selling the equipment so they're not
really your advisers right and so we've
decided that now after the port is
operational and the industrial zone is
successful and we have all residential
that this is an area we will focus on in
the next 24 months actually implementing
the smart city model so I've been here
talking to companies in the valley about
changing the experience for a resident
in a city empowering them to actually
run the city through technology right so
you need the obviously the fiber network
and all of the goodies that come with a
smart city base more about how do you
actually operate the city how do I know
within my home not only how much energy
I'm using but which of my appliances is
least efficient which one I would how
why can't my app just calculate which
one I should buy on a business case
basis if I remove that iron and buy
another one it will pay for itself in
seven months or two years or three years
that can be instantaneous if you are so
there are so many ideas we are looking
at for example the idea of that smart
fridge anybody heard about a smart
fridge mmm-hmm it knows exactly how much
you have in it obviously nobody's gonna
develop that right and can be very
simple what what if I scanned everything
that just a scanner on my application
right just a scanner of all of the items
that I have
and every time I use when I just scan it
again it tells me exactly what I'm
missing why need that can contact Amazon
a drone can fly in yes but the idea is
how can we be practical about the other
project is we're the initiative we're
launching is the perfect home and the
perfect home is trying to optimize a
home for aesthetics technology
sustainability but the trick is to do it
at the middle income level because you
can scale it's easy to build the next
greatest home with all of the bells or
whistles of Technology right but that
will not be affordable and not scalable
the trick is to optimize for a
middle-income home that way when you go
to affordable you can just cut out a cut
you know remove some of the options and
when you go to high end you can just add
more options so we're launching that
also with many companies in the valley
so these are the big opportunities for
me who has a mic I have the mic there
are two mics what's going on no at the
same time okay thank you so much for
coming here at the GSB we always hear
about the importance of culture but I
think I've had an opportunity to ask
anyone what is it like to shape the
culture of a city and if is that
something you do and how do you do it
specifically in the context of Saudi
Arabia which has a pretty highly defined
culture yeah okay I'm really good at
knowing that I'm not good at okay and
definitely social engineering is not an
agenda of mine it's tempting to do it
but the reality you read you realize
that actually people who move at the
beginning to a city will shape its
culture they will have their own dynamic
all you can do is not get in the way the
the thing we are trying to instill
though is citizenship through engagement
that the idea that this is your city
it's not mine it's not our employee it
is the resident city and so we launched
an app many of you might have used it
called public works basically allows you
to
if you see a pothole on the street or
something that's not working you can
send it immediately and we will actually
track that and how long it takes our
people to go actually and fix it so it
gives you a sense of ownership that you
can actually that you are the mayor of
the city that we don't have a mayor you
are the mayor so that kind of engagement
is very important in terms of how how
citizens feel and about the city and
about efficiency of its operations I'd
like to shift gears slightly actually if
I remember your presentation correctly
you said you join Amara at the age of 30
and despite having an MBA from what is
unquestionably the best business school
in the world you are really young leader
in charge of a really big project so I'm
curious if that you face any challenges
because of that and then what you did to
establish credibility as a young leader
in a new organization yeah it was
actually a big challenge because I had
no engineering background I've never
been like I said anything before in my
life I had a a finance background so I
did lots of modeling and the biggest
challenge at the time was the business
model it worked and really it's about
leadership realizing that I'm not
supposed to be building every sector of
the city and the challenge is can you
attract the talent to allow you to get
the snow how and actually to build the
best of the best so the example of you
know I've met many Silicon Valley
companies during this trip over the past
two days and they all say okay how are
you going to do it I said I'm not gonna
do it well that's why I'm here
I'm supposed to be working with the best
of the best so why should I come and and
try to reinvent the wheel and something
you're already doing and so the idea is
how can you make decisions on who to
work with how to attract talent
companies and people by the way it's not
only about people individuals and the
third is around getting people to accept
your decisions because in this you make
lots of mistakes lots of mistakes and
Republik company this could be actually
very dangerous for an executive so the
idea is about being transparent with you
know in this case
my board our employees about the kind of
risk we are taking and the potential
outcomes so you go back to decision
trees and and analysis and actually we
just you know make mistakes all the time
but if you're making a hundred decisions
and three of them go wrong you hope that
the those are not the three big ones
that you made but but you you you create
a culture of learning and to be honest
that's learning by doing
and this has been the hardest thing
because you get employees from different
companies who are not used to it and
they judge each other yeah they say look
we made a mistake should be fired this
is the way people are used to doing and
I say look you know if we do one one of
these examples you know obviously if
there were intelligent that's something
else but if they actually had made the
diligent effort looked at all aspects
and just the market and didn't turn out
the way they expected it then that's
okay you make one of these decisions you
fire one person because they make it
made a market decision and then you will
kill innovation in an organization
because people just don't want to take
risk anymore so we try to avoid that as
much as possible thank you for coming
my question is to to the purpose of the
city again and you mentioned that you
know 23% of the global freight volumes I
think kind of go right by right by that
city which is great but they go right by
the city without the city even being in
existence
so once the city is there and once you
have a top ten port worldwide how are
you gonna take part in that in that in
that logistics flow
how you gonna improve it well you know I
talked about capacity by the way our
capacity is already full because the
shipping lines are already moving to
Camden economic City two of the top five
shipping lines around the world are
coming here because they told us that
they need a port under Etsy so ports
work like big airports you know the
hub-and-spoke model it's the same thing
it doesn't matter what size of the port
it is what matters is which airlines go
there and so the idea is this will be a
hub and then you'll get smaller
ships serving all of the countries
around us so that that's basic I did
time for one last question
hi Maya my question was you talked about
in 10 years you wanted to think about
how you're gonna feel how did you pick
the industry that you were gonna work in
because that's a big question and I
always hear I did it I didn't I
you're gonna laugh I did a spreadsheet
and I you know try to optimize all of my
opportunities along the make an impact
make enough money so I don't have to
worry about it you know and I every
decision was just and that's the
condition I wanted to be in 10 years I
wanted to be in a place where I had
major impact where you know I I was
learning having fun and that I was
financially secure honestly that was it
and then I every opportunity ever came I
just said looking how does it get me
closer and you have to prioritize
because it's nice to have everything but
you have to say this is next and I and I
learned that again it's about not taking
the path of least resistance that's the
most dangerous thing because it might
seem like you're taking a lot more risk
at the beginning but turns out that at
that age you could take it and still
survive it is later in life that you
can't take these vicar's so you know I'm
not encouraging you to take risks or say
I'm just saying in my example taking the
right risks ultimately has developed my
character has given me more experience
because I just worked harder earlier on
and that has resulted in me being in a
place where honestly I would have never
had imagined doing doing this before so
you